[Applaudissements]
gérard terminé le titre de cette pièce
le père noël est une c'est pas évident
c'est pas et qui sont fascinés malawi
perdrait le pouvoir elle ira dans la
merde non intérimaire dans et c'est le
père noël est une ordure il est accusé
par cette équipe je trouve formidable
manière de recycler même lycée sabatier
rien ne se perd ici à nommer ici rien
mais depuis tout à l'heure j'ai calé
gens là vanessa qui vous demandent de
tous les personnages que vous avez
interprété lequel est celui qui
ressemble le plus à l'homme que vous
êtes dans la vraie vie le foot c'est mal
et ça a dû sa part et surtout très
gentil mais ça j'ai beaucoup de chance
d'entrer chez moi vous aimez un discours
et labouré face à lui ce que vous aurez
pu lui dire tout simplement que tu l'as
vu mon cul
scusez la fira j'essaie mais la fatigue
je vais jouer mon gage ou parler des
gages que vous avez mois s'engager sur
tes sorte ça marche tu sois dire tu la
réponse qui ça